[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر
قمه الجزائر تؤكدوها على مبدا عدم
الانحياز في الحرب الاوكرانيه وتقدير
الحوار عن استخدام القوه
في طريقه للحكم على
ظهر معسكر اليمين اليسار يتحدث عن يوم
اسود والقوائم العربيه محلات اكثر
السويد
على عصب روسي بانفتاحه ما على نشر النووي
نووي الناتو وموسكو تعتبروا منع اصطدام
النووي اولويه
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
السياسيه والقانونيه وفي واشنطن خاسر
[موسيقى]
اكد بيان الجزائر الالتزام بي مبادئ عدم
الانحياز وبالموقف العربي المشترك من
الحرب في اوكرانيا الذي يقوموا على نبذ
استعمال القوه والسعي لتفعيل خيار السلامه
واشار البيان الى دعم مجموعه الاتصال
الوزريه العربيه في الجهود الدوليه
الراميه لبلوره حل سياسيا للازمه يتوافقون
مع مبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده ويراعي
الشواغل الامنيه للاطراف المعنيه مع رفض
تاسيس المنظمات الدوليه واشد البيان في
هذا السياق بالمساعي التي قامت بها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه التي تستضيف
القمه العربيه المقبله في دورتها الثانيه
والثلاثين كما اعلن وزير خارجيتها الامير
فيصل بن فرحه
البيان والختامي للقمه العربيه الحاديه
والثلاثين اكد على مركزيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه والدعم المطلق لحقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني غير القابله للتصرف وشدد البيان
على تمسكي بمبادره السلام العربيه لعام
2002 بكافه عناصرها
واولوياتها كما اكد البيان على ضروره
مواصله الجهود والمساعي الرميه لحمايه
مدينه القدس المحتله ومقدساتها ورفع
الحصار الاسرائيلي عن قطاع غزه وادانه
استخدام القوه من قبل السلطات الاسرائيليه
والتاكيد على تبني ودعم حصولي دوله فلسطين
على العضويه الكامله في الامم المتحده
هذا وثمنا اعلان الجزائر في ختام القمه
العربيه الموقف المتوازن لمنظمه اوبك بلس
واشار الى ان قرارات ابك بلس تضمن استقرار
الاسواق العالميه للطاقه واستدامه
الاستثمارات في هذا القطاع الحساسه ضمن
مقارنه مقاربه اقتصاديه لحمايه مصالح
الدول المنتجه والمستهلكه على حد سواء
كلمته امام القمه العربيه في الجزائر شدد
وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان على الاعتزاز بالقيم المستقاه من
الديانه الاسلاميه والثقافه العربيه مؤكدا
عدم التنازل عنها وعدم السماح للاخرين
بفرد قيامهم على دول العربيه واكد الامير
فيصل بن فرحان على احترام قيم وثقفات
الاخرين لذلك يجب على الاخرين احترام
الثقافه العربيه وشدد وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه على ضروره العمل على اصلاح
منظومه العمل العربيه
تواجه العديله من دولنا العربيه تحديات
عده
ليس على امن تلك الدول واستقرارها
المنطقه القديمه ككل من اهمها التدخلات
الخارجيه في الشؤون الداخليه
واننا في المملكه العربيه السعوديه نسعى
دائما الى توفير الظروف الملائمه لتحقيق
ذلك من خلال التعاون والتنسيق مع اشقائنا
في الدول العربيه
والاولياتنا في هذا الجانب تحقيق الامن
الغذائي الذي يعد من اهم الاولويات لدى
العديد من دول العالم وتركدوا المملكه في
هذا الاطار على اهميه العمل العربي
الجماعي واستثمار امكانات المحيط العربي
من ثروات طبيعيه
وتنوع الحيوي وغذائي في سد احتياج اسواق
الغذاء العربي
هنا الاعتزاز نابقيه من المستقام من
شريعتنا الاسلاميه السمحاه ومن ثقافه
العربيه الاصيله والتي لن نتنازل عنها ولن
نسمح للاخرين بفرض قيامهم علينا وبما اننا
نحترم قيم وثقافات الاخرين
ان يحترم الاخرون ذلك
ترغب في التوصل الى تسويه سياسيه في ليبيا
دون تدخلات واملائه خارجيه مؤكدا انه يجب
ان تشمل اي تسويه سياسيه في ليبيا خروج
المرتزقه الاجنبي
ان اشارككم هنا رغبتنا في دعمكم
الشقيقه للتوصل في اسرع وقت الى تسويه
سياسيه بقياده وملكيه ليبيه خالصه دون
املاءات خارجيه اصولا الى اجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه بالتزامن واحترام مؤسسات
الدوله
وصلاحياتها بمقدار الاتفاقات
وتنفيذ خروج جميع القوات الاجنبيه
والمرتزقه والمقاتلين الاجانب في مدى زمني
محدد واعاده توحيد مؤسسه الدوله الليبيه
وحلل من الشات بما يحول دون تجدد
المواجهات العسكريه ويعيد البلاد وحدتها
وسيادتها واستقرارها
في الشؤون الداخليه بهدف فرد الهايم عليها
لقد مر على المنطقه للاسف الشديد
عقد صعب صعب للغايه ولا زالت بعض الدول
العربيه تعيش تعيش اوضاعا لا تهدد فقط
امنها واستقرارها بل وجودها ذاته
لازالت الدوله الوطنيه
ذات السياده
والاستقلال والقرار المستقل تتعرض لهجمه
شرسه في بعض اركان المنطقه العربيه من
الارهاب
والجماعات المسلحه وايضا من اطراف غير
عربيه في جوار الاقليم العربيه
وتمارس تدخلات غير حميده في المجتمعات
العربيه بهدف بسط النفوس
وتحقيق الهيمنه
حول مخرجات قمه الجزائر ينضم الينا من
عمان استاذ العلاقات الدوليه وفضل
النزاعات الدكتور حسن المومني اهلا بك
دكتور حسن معنا الليله يعني قمه الجزائر
اذا اكدت في بيانها الختام على مبدا عدم
الانحياز
بالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه الى اي مدى
برايك التزام الدول العربيه بهذا المبدا
يخدم مصالحها نتحدث عن المصالح الاقتصاديه
وايضا السياسيه
يا مساء الخير لكي والمشاهدين ترامب مما
لا شك فيه الموقف العام الموقف العربي
الغير منحاز حقيقه في صراع لا مصلحه للعرب
في بهذا الجانب كلنا يعلم بان الاطراف
العربيه تتمتع بعلاقات استراتيجيه
ومتوازنه مع كثير من الاطراف الصراع بهذا
الجانب هذا الامر اضيف الى ذلك التاثيرات
العالميه لهذه الصراع والتي ايضا طالت
المنطقه العربيه فبالتالي بتقدير الشخصي
ان المواقف يتم اتخاذها بناء على المصالح
ومصالح الدول العربيه همم لا تقتضي ان
يكون هنالك موقف عربي منحاز لموقف اخر لكن
بتقدير الشخص المواقف العربيه وبالذات
الدول الوازنه
يعني كانت مواقفها واضحه بهذا الاتجاه لا
تدعم الاحتلال لكن بنفس الوقت لابد ان يجد
هنالك نوع من الحل السياسي والدبلوماسي
مثلا العربيه السعوديه عند الحديث على
العربيه السعوديه تبرعت ب 400 مليون يورو
اوكرانيا بنفس الوقت ادانت في الجمعيه
العامه مساله الضم لكن ايضا
انتهجت موقف متوازن بمعنى عدم السماح
بالحياز الى طرف اخر بهذا الجانب ومن هنا
ايضا جاءت المصلحه العامه في موقف همم
الدول الاوروبيك بلس والتي تلعب العربيه
السعوديه دورا محوريه وذات مكانه في هذا
الجانب وبناءا على اسس اقتصاديه وبناءا
على اساس مرتبطه بمصالح جميع الاطراف سواء
كانت الاطراف المنتجه او المستهلكه في هذا
الامر واعتقد ان الموقف العربي همم من
الاهميه بمكان بحيث ان هنالك جهد عربي
حقيقه تفاعل مع المجتمع الدولي من اجل ان
يكون للعرب ايضا كلمه في مساله حولات اللي
بتحصل الان في في ميزان القوه في في
النزعه التقليديه لا تعصب بالعالم
بالتقدير الشخصي نرى موقفا عربيا ايجابيا
بهذا الامر يمكن دول معينه زي السعوديه
انتهجت والان جاء الموقف العربي همم بشكل
جمعي بهذا الامر واكد عليه فلذلك وايضا قد
يكون الموقف العربي من صالح الاطراف
المعنيه في النزاع وفي الخلاف بهذا الجانب
كله لا يذكر مثلا كيف لعبت السعوديه دورا
مثلا الدوري الوسيط في مساله تبادل الاسرى
يعني
عن الوساطه السعوديه وايضا الاماراتيه ان
كان همم الافراج عن الرهائن او حتى تقريبا
وجهه النظر يعني انهاء هذه الحرب الروسيه
الاخرانيه فعليا الى اي مدى ذلك يبرز قيمه
هذا الحياد العربي السلام العالمي وبملفات
ايضا تحديدا
يعني عندما يكون ال ال ال ال ال الوسيط ده
حياديه ذات مصداقيه يستطيع ان يؤثر خاصه
في هذا النوع من النزاعات وكما اسباب
سابقا العرب ودول وازنه مثل العربيه
السعوديه تتمتع بعلاقات قويه مع كل
الاطراف وبالتالي تكون اكثر قبولا ويمكن
في مرحله معينه في الصراع لابد ان يكون
هنالك طرف ثالث
يتمتع بهذه الصفات من اجل مساعده الاطراف
وبتقدير الشخص بين قوسين انزالهم عن
الشجره من اجل ان يكون هنالك حل بهذا
الجانب وبهذا الاتجاه اضيف الى ذلك بتقدير
الخاص الدوري العربي وبالذات السعودي ليس
فقط في موضوع اوكرانيا كلنا يعلم انه الان
هنالك فلسطين كلاعب رئيسي والعلاقات
المتوازنه مع الصين وهنالك القيمه التي
سوف تعقد في السعوديه هذه كلها في سياق
دولي قد يسهم بشكل كبير في حال حاله همم
كثير من النزاعات اضافه الى الجهود
الاقتصاديه وخاصه عندما يتعلق الامر بها
من الطاقه والامن الغذائي شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا من عمان الدكتور حسن المؤمن
[موسيقى]
انتخابات الكنيست الاسرائيلي انتهت يوم
امس ونتائجها الاوليه خالفت بشكل كبير
استطلاعات الراي التي استبعدت فوزه تكتل
بالنصف زائد واحد نتناول في هذا العرض
مشاركه العرب في هذه الانتخابات والتي
زادت بعشره في المئه مقارنه بالانتخابات
الماضيه ورغم دعوات المقاطعه وعدم استشعار
فرق جوهري بين يمين ويسار الا ان حملات
اليمين الاسرائيلي والخوف من تصاعد التيار
الديني اليهودي لعبا دورا في زياده
التصويت العربي وفي هذه الانتخابات دخل
العرب السباق بثلاث قوائم منفصله هي
القائمه الموحده بقياده منصور عباس
والتجمع بقياده سامي ابو شحاده وقائمه
ثنائيه تضم الجبهه الديمقراطيه للسلام
والمساواه
رئاسه ايمن عوده والعربيه للتغيير برئاسه
احمد الطبي النتائج الاوليه تشير الى ان
عدد المقاعد العربيه يحوم حول الرقم 10
على ان لا يتجاوزه وبهذا يستمر انخفاض عدد
المقاعد العربيه في الكنيست التي وصلت الى
15 مقعدا في انتخابات عام 2015 عندما
شاركت الاحزاب بقائمه موحده الامر المؤكد
في النتائج غير النهائيه للانتخابات
الاسرائيليه ان قائمه التجمع الوطني
الديمقراطي لم تتجاوز عتبه الحزم والتي
تبلغ ثلاثه وربع في المئه لتتمكن من دخول
المسجد
عام 2014 بناء على اقتراح من زعيم حزب
اسرائيل بيتنا افك دار ليبرمن وتشييع من
بنيامين نتنياهو لمنع القوائم العربيه من
الوصول الى الكنيسه
[موسيقى]
كم ذكرنا امس في انتخابات الكنيسه جرت تحت
ظلال التهم الموجهه لرئيس الوزراء الاسبق
بنيامين نتنياهو نتعرف على هذه التهم
سوريه
من عام 2020 في 30 قضايا القضايا تحمل
قاسما مشتركا وهو الغش وخيانه الامانه
الاولى هي القضيه الالف ويتهم بموجبها
نتنياهو بتلقي هدايا من رجال اعمال ذوي
نفوذ مقابل خدمات سياسيه تقدم لهم القضيه
الثانيه هي القضيه الفان وفيها وجهت لينه
ياهو تهمه عرض مساعده لصحيفه يدعوت على
تحسين توزيعها مقابل ان يحصل هو على تغطيه
صحفيه تصب في صالحه القضيه الثالثه
والاخيره هي القضيه اربعه الاف
رغم ان نتنياهو وقت ما كان رئيسا للوزراء
اضافه لشغله حقيبه الاتصال شجع اتخاذ
قرارات حكوميه لصالح شوال الوفيتش كبير
حاملي اسهم شركه اتصالات محليه مقابل
الحصول على تغطيه ايجابيه من موقع اخباري
يمتلكه الوفيتش بدوره ينفي نتنياه بشده
جميع التهم الموجهه اليه ويصفها بحمله من
خصومه السياسيين ضده متعهدا بتطهير سمعته
وفقا للقانون الاسرائيلي لا يطلب من رئيس
الحكومه المتهم بارتكاب جريمه الاستقاله
من منصبه ولم تشهد اسرائيل امرا مماثلا
سابقا حتى مع الانقسام الداخلي بين من
يقولون ان المحاكمه تجعله غير ملائم
لمنصبه في مواجهه دعم الذين يقولون انه
انتخب بشكل ديمقراطي ويجب عدم اجباره على
الاستقاله هنا نذكر بان رئيس الوزراء
السابق يهود اولمرت الذي استقال من رئاسه
حزبه عندما كان يخضع لتحقيق بيتهم فساد
عام 2008 لكنه بقي رئيسا للوزراء حتى
انتخابات العام التالي كما ان اول مره لم
يدخل السجن الا عام 2016 بعد استكمالي
الاجراءات القانونيه وفي حال ما ان صدر
حكم ضد نتنياهو فلن يجبر على الاستقاله
قبل الاستنفاد
فرص الاستئناف وهو الامر الذي قد يستغرق
شهورا او سنوات كما حدث مع اولمرت مثلا
[موسيقى]
قبل الحديث عن الانتخابات الاسرائيليه
نذهب لنشاهد هذا الفيديو الذي وصلنا منذ
قليل اشتباكات واطلاق نار من الامن تجاه
المحتاجين في منطقه تشكر في طهران اذا كما
نشاهد بهذه الصور
اطلاق نار وصراخ
بين محتجين
[موسيقى]
قوات امن على ما يبدو
في العاصمه طهران تحديدا في منطقه شيكر
مبكر بان
مشاهدينا بانه الاحتجاجات ما زلت مستمره
في
اغلب المحافظات وجميع فعليا المحافظات
الايرانيه منذ مقتل الشاب مهس اميني على
يد شرطه الاخلاق
نعود الى ضيفنا للحديث عن النتائج الغير
رسميه والاوليه لانتخابات الكنيسه من
الناصره وديع الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا
بك سيد وديع بما يخص القوائم العربيه ثلاث
قوائم نزلت متفرقه
الموضوع طبعا سيكون له نتائج
اغلب التقارير تتحدث بانه لن يكون للعرب
اكثر من 10 مقاعد في الكنيسه العربي هل
الخلافات بين هذه
اللوائح والجهات اهم كانت من انه يحصل
العرب على مقاعد اكثر
للاسف احيانا تدخل اعتبارات والمصالح
والحسابات الشخصيه والحسنيه
والحسابات الايجو والانا على الحسابات
والمصالح الوطنيه الكبرى وهذا ما يحدث في
السياسه وفي اسرائيل بالتحديد يحدث ولكن
طبعا هذا الامر بالغ الحساسيه حينما يرتبط
باكمليه قوميه وباخليه تتعرض يوميا الى
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه ولذلك كان هذا من
الامور التي يعني كانت بالامكان فيها خاصه
وان الحديث كان يدور عن الخلافات موضوعيه
محدوده كان بالامكان فيها وتجاوزها ولكن
ينبغي التنبيه حتى لا نكون يعني في موضع
نسطح الامور هناك يعني استنتاج همم يبدو
للمره او للوهره وكانه
اتحاد هذه القواعد العربيه في قائمه واحده
من شانها يرفع نسبه التمثيل العربي في
الكنيسه
ولكن انا اقول لك ان هذا ليس مضمونا لان
في داخل كل حزب هناك تيار يرفض التحالف مع
الطرف الاخر وهذا الارتفاع في نسب التصويت
جاء على خلفيه الذات الانقسام الذي حصل
وخاصه جمهور التجمع الوطني الديمقراطي
الذي لم ينجح بتجاوز نسبه الحسيمه ولكن
انتبه حتى لو كان يعني
التمثيل العربي اكثر بقليل يعني زاد
بالمقعد او مقعدين ارتفاع نسبه التصويت في
الجانب اليهودي كانت كافيه لان يكون
نتنياه همم كما هو الحال اليوم على حتى
تشكيل الحكومه سادس في اسرائيل لان نسب
التصويت في الشارع اليهودي ارتفعت جدا
نتيجه الصراع الكبير على السلطه مما ادى
الى يعني تقليل الحجم الصوت العربي وقيمه
النوعيه
كما يبدو انه فاز وس- يعني يشكل حكومه هو
لا راسها عاد بفضل اليمين المتطرف كيف
سيرد هذا الدين وباي ملفات تحديدا
على ما يبدو الى تشكيل حكومه ضيقه مكونه
او تعتمد على اغلبيه 65 او اغلبيه 61 بحال
ان حزت ميرس اليسار الصهيوني عاد الى
الكنيسه لانه حتى الان لا يعبر نسبه الحسن
لانه عمليه فرش الاصوات لم تكتمل بعد هناك
لا يزال امل ان ايه يخرج حزب مارس الى
الحياه من جديد ولكن بكل الاحوال رئيس
حكومه وسيكون رئيس حكومه ضيقه وبالتالي هو
اسير سياسي لهذه الاحزاب اليمنيه الصغيره
ولكن هناك ايضا من يعتبر ان نتنه يريد مثل
هذا الحكومه الصغيره الطريقه لان ببساطه
هو في مثل هذه الحكومه المنسجمه داخليا
بين مكوناتها يستطيع ان يبادر الى اجراءات
وتسريعات قضائيه تتيح عمليه الغاء محاكمته
بالتالي النجاه من ذهب الفساد الخطيرات
لاسيه
لا يرى هناك ثمنا ستدفعه اسرائيل في
العالم ومن قبل المستوى المجتمع الدولي في
حال اتكى او اعتمد على احزاب يمنيه متطرفه
كحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه حتى الان كل
العالم متى يعلم ان المجتمع الدولي يكتفي
بضرائب شفويه لا توجد هناك خطوات فعليه
على اسرائيل ولذلك نتنياه اعتقد لن ياخذ
هذه الضغوط او هذا العتب الدولي عليه في
حال شكله مثل هذه الحكومه المتطاهره حتى
وان كان هناك تحفظات امريكيه او كانت
انتقادات محتمله من قبل الدول الغربيه
تابعونا ولكن بعد الفاصل
النسخه في البرازيل تلحقه بالاصلي في وقت
زعامه سياسيه من دون منصب وملاحقات قضائيه
لا تنتهي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد القنبله القذره تكرر هذا
المصطلح مؤخرا بعد زعم روسيا ان اوكرانيا
تستعد لاستخدامها وهذا ما نفاه فريق امامي
زار موقع عين اشارت لهما موسكو باعتبارهما
يحتضمان القنبله المزعومه لينتقل الحديث
اليوم عن نيه مسبقه للكراملين باستخدام
هذه القنبله على اراضي الجاره الغربيه لكن
مع اختلاف جذري في القنبله القذره الروسيه
ليست شبيهه بالاوكرانيه المزعومه انما هي
قنبله نوويه بتاثير اقل من نظيرتها
النوويه التقليديه فبينما تحصي روسيا
خسارها تتصاعد تهديداتها بالاسلحه ويجد
القاده الغربيون انفسهم مضطرين للتعامل مع
احتمال ان موسكوت اخطط لتصعيد دراماتيكي
في ساحه المعركه بالفعل تطور من شانه ان
حصل ان يترك الولايات المتحده وحلف شمال
الاطلسي امام مجموعه محدوده من الخيارات
للاستجابه والرضعه على روسيا
يتتبع الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ومستشاروخ
عن كثب اشارات لكراملين التي راى بعيدا
انها تجعل العالم اقرب الى هرمجدون او حرب
نهايه العالم اكثر من اي وقت مضى منذ ازمه
الصواريخ الكوبيه حذر المسؤولون
الامريكيون علنا من ان اي تحرك من جانب
روسيا لتنفيذي تهديداته باستخدام اسلحه
نوويه سيتم الرد عليه بشكل حاسم ما عواقب
وخيمه وزير الدفاع لولد اوستن قال لي
الصحفيين الاسبوع الماضي ان الحديث عن
استخدام سلاح من هذا النوع خطير وغير
مسؤوله واذا حدث ف- سنرى ردا مهما للغايه
[موسيقى]
لكن ما ماهيه الرد الامريكي والغربي ان
نفذ الكلام لن تهدي ذاته اعترض مسؤول
الاداره الامريكيه عندما طلب منهم تحديد
شكل هذا الرد مبشرين الى الحاجه الى
الغموض الاستراتيجي واهميه ابقاء خياراتهم
مفتوحه لكن رغم ذلك قد تكون ايدي الاداره
الامريكيه مقيده اكثر مما يرغب ممثلوها في
الاعتراف به قد تكون العقوبات وسيله واضحه
لعقاب موسكو لكن بعض الخبراء يخشون من ان
التحركات الاقتصاديه العقابيه لن تكون
كافيه لوحدها لاخداع بوتن تنقل صحيفه
واشنطن
الموظف السابق في وزاره الخارجيه قوله ان
العقوبات ليست كافيه للغداء بل يجب ان
تكون واشنطن مستعده لاستخدام القوه
العسكريه قد يكون الرد العسكري اذا عرضا
اكثر قوه لكن هجوما انتقاميا على المصالح
الروسيه يخ باشعال حرب بين الناتو وروسيا
وهو امر حاولت اداره بايدن تجنبه حتى الان
ففكره مواجهه ضرب نوويه بضربه نوويه اخرى
وفقا للخبراء غير مطروحه صراحه على
الطاوله وهذا يترك الولايات المتحده في
منطقه مجهوله استراتيجيه
اذا يتمحور القلق المتزايد بشانه هجوم
اشعاعي روسي حول سيناريوهين اثنين رئيسيين
اما استخدام موسكو لقنبله قذره او للسلاح
النووي تكتيكي ضد اوكرانيا لكن الناتو لا
يقف متفرجا على ما يبدا هذا ليس الان
وانما من ايام الرئيس الاسبق جوايت ايزن
هاوس في منتصف خمسينات القرن الماضي عندما
نشرت واشنطن قنابل نوويه في خمس دول
اوروبيه لردعي الاتحاد السوفيتي حينها
ولطمئنه الحلفاء المتوجين في القاره
العجوز ويبدو ان التوجه من السوفيات استمر
الى ابنهم بوتن اليوم مع اعلان السويد
استعدادها لاستضافه الاسلحه النوويه على
اراضيها حال اتمام انضمامها الى الحلف
الاطلسي اذا الاعلان السويدي جاء على لسان
رئيس وزراء الجديد
شوف كريسترسون ولميحا الى
نيه مشابهه لدى جارته في اللنده وذلك رغم
التحفظات نظيرته الفنلنديه سانا مارين عن
الاجابه الصريحه بشان هذا الموضوع قائله
انه لا ينبغي ان نضع اي شروط مسبقه لقد
قررنا اننا لا نريد اغلاق اي ابواب
للمستقبل لكن الجرتين الاسكندنافيه
الدنمارك والنروج العدوين اصلا في الناتو
رفضتا السماح للدول الاجنبيه بانشاء قواعد
عسكريه دائمه او نشر اسلحه نوويه على
اراضيهم في وقت السلم
ولرئيسه وزراء فنلندا راي اخر سنه
ابلكيشن يتم الان التصديق على طلبات النت
الخاصه بنا في جميع الدول الاعضاء ولا
يزال هناك دولتان لم تصادقه وهما المجر
وتركيا ومن المهم جدا بالنسبه لنا بالطبع
ان تنضم فنلندا والسويد الى الناتو ستعزز
عضويتنا في الحلف امنى بلدين فضلا عن امن
شمال اوروبا بالكامل
بالعوده الى الاسلحه النوويه الامريكيه في
اوروبا عمليا لا تفتح واشنطن او النيترو
عن العدد الدقيق لهذه الاسلحه لكن
التقديرات تتراوح بين 100 قنبله حدا ادنى
ومئتين قنبله حدا اقصى غالبيه القنابل من
نوع بي 61 ونسخه المحدثه منها مسمات
بواحد واا 60 12 تنشر واشنطن قنابل نوويه
في قواعد عسكريه
بروج في بلجيكا
وشال الجويه في المانيا وقاعده افيانو
وجيدي الجاويتين في ايطاليا وقاعده فلك
الجويه في هولندا وانجل لك في تركيا فيما
تشارك سبع دول اخرى عبر برنامج سنوكات في
تقديمي الدعم للمهام النوويه عبر توفير
الدعم الجوي التق وهي تشيك و الدنمارك
واليونان والمجر والنرويج وبولندا
ورومانيا ووفقا لمركز الحد من التسلح ومنع
انتشار الانتشار النووي ومقره واشنطن فان
تلك القنابل النوويه مخزنه تحت حراسه
القوات الجويه الامريكيه وهي جاهزه
للتحميل على متن مقاتلات كل دوله القنابل
هذه ليست مسلحه او محمله على متن مقاتله
لكنها مخزنه تحت الارض وتبقى ارقامها
التسلسليه لتفعلها في اياد امريكيه
لكن رغم حديث الطرفين عن استبعاد الخيار
النووي راى مسؤول دفاعي كبير تحدث
للصحفيين الاسبوع الماضي شريطه عدم الكشف
عن هويته ان التاثير العملي لاستنفاذ
الروس لقواتهم التقليديه هو للاسف اعتماد
اكبر على قوتهم النوويه لكن ان استخدم
بوتن النووي سيخاطر ليس بالدمار المتبادل
مع الغرب بل بفقدان اخر حلفائه المتبقين
والمقصود هنا الصين والهند ظلت بكين وان
يدالهي وهما قوتان نوويتان على الحياد الى
حد كبير بشان الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
لكن خبراء يشككون في ان الدولتين ستقفان
الى جانب موسكو اذا استخدمت سلاح النوويه
تنقل واشنطن بوست عن خبير قوله انه اذا
اظهر اخر اصدقاء روسيا المتبقيين ازدراءهم
لاستخدام سلاح فيمكن ان يسحب البساطه من
تحت مجهود موسكو الحربي باكمله فمع
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه قد تكسب المعركه
لكن ليس الحرب وبالتاكيد في الحرب النوويه
لن يربح احد او اياك
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من باريس
الدكتور انطوان بصوص الكاتب السياسي اهلا
بك دكتور بصبوص يعني السويد وفنلندا بدايه
يعني عدم الممانعه بنشر همم سلاح نووي على
الحدود طبعا الحدود المشتركه مع روسيا
لماذا الحديث عن هذا الموضوع لماذا نشر
اسلحه نوويه همم مع روسيا الان وما فائده
هذا الاستفزاز في هذا التوقيت بالذات
مساء الخير في الواقع هاتان الدولتان
كانتا حياديه حتى اطلاق عمليه اجتياح
اوكرانيا واذا بهما تخافان مما جري عند
الروس ومن محاوله الغزو الروسي لجارتهم
اوكرانيا فلذلك هناك تكرار من قبل الرئيس
الروسي ومن قبل مسؤولين عديدين بان هناك
امكانيه لاستخدام النووي فهذه الدول
انضمت الى الناتو وتريد ان تتامن على
مستقبلها وان تكون مظله انه حقيقيه ولكن
هناك همم سلاح نووي اميرتي وفرنسي
وبريطاني
يجوب المحيطات وهناك غواصات نوويه قريبه
من من الاراضي الروسيه ولا نعرف اين هي
ولكن ليس فقط السلاح النووي ليس فقط موجود
مركون في اوروبا انه في البحار انه في
الولايات المتحده انه في قواعد يعني
مختلفه في دول عديده ولا نعرف بالضبط اين
هي هذه الغواصات التي تغوص في عمق البحار
انه في حال اللجوء الى ال ال السلاح
النووي هناك خاسر او رابح لماذا لا يلتقط
الغرب هذه الاشارات الايجابيه يعني لماذا
دائما ان كان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
او حلف الناته هناك تركيز بانه روسيا
ستلجا الى سلاح النووي لماذا لا يتم هناك
حوار
ما المشكله ان روسيا اقدمت على اجتياح
جارتها وهي كانت تتوقع ان تدوم النزهه
اسبوع او 10 ايام وتاخذ العاصمه كاف
وتنتهي الامور واذا بها اليوم بعد تسعه
اشهر اا غارقه في الوحول وتتقهقر فلذلك
نجد ان المسؤولين الروس يبحثون عن عمليات
تخويف خارج ارض المعركه مثلا تجميع العالم
الثالث ويقطع الامدادات الحبوب والقمح
عنهم مثلا ضرب البنى التحتيه المدنيه في
اوكرانيا هذا ليست في ساحه المعركه في
ساحه القتال ولكي تعوض عن هذا التقصير في
ساحه القتال ماذا تعمل موسكو تهدد بالنووي
تلوح به تريد ان تقول يعني وقفوني والا
سانتر جريمه كبرى
هم الروس هم في حاله في زق كبير وعليهم ان
ينسحبوا وتنتهي الامور ولكن اذا ارادوا
اجتياح جارتهم وضم من قسم من اراديها
عليهم ان يتوقعوا النتيجه اي الطلب من
الروس ان ينسحبوا من اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
في البرازيل سكنت المخاوف ولو مؤقتا من
الفوضى بعد ان اعلن الرئيس المنتهيه
ولايته جرير بولس سونارو انه سيحترم
الدستور حتى ولم يقر رسميا بالهزيمه لكن
رئيس مكتبه اعلن ان بوسنارو اعطى الامر
ببدء عمليه انتقال السلطه مع الرئيس
المنتخب لولا السيلفا وعلى الفور التقط
فريق عمل لولا الاشاره وقال انه يريد ان
تبدا العمليه الانتقاليه الخميس الامور
تبدو مطمئنه الى حد كبير اا عند هذه
النقطه خاصه بعد ان اصدرت المحكمه العليا
بيانا جاء فيه ان بول سونار واقر بالنتيجه
النهائيه للانتخابات لكن ما هو غير مطمئن
ان احتجاجات انصار
وتواصلت خاصه من قائدي الشاحنات الذين
يستطيعون بيسهوله شال الطرق
حين خاطبها هؤلاء دعاهم للالتزام
بالاحتجاجات السلميه وان لا يقلده اليسار
لكن لو ختم تصريحه بعباره مهمه التظاهرات
هي ثمرات الغضب والشعور بالغن في
الاستحقاق الرئاسي وحتى في المؤتمر الوحيد
الذي ظهر فيه فول سونارو التقط المذياع
المفتوح بعظا مما تمتم به الرجل قبل كلمته
كان يقول سيشتقون الينا ليست هذه كلمات
الرجل الوحيده المثيره للجدل فلديه تاريخ
طويل قبل سنه تقريبا
اكثر رجلا قال حينها لمنصرين امامي ثلاث
احتمالات للمستقبل ان اسجل او اموت او ان
تنتصر وختم بالتاكيد على ان الخيار الاول
اي السجن غير واردا اطلاقا كان بول سونار
يشير في هذا التوقيت الى تحقيقات عده همم
عطلت ما يتعلق بتقديمه معلومات مضلله وسوء
ادارتها لازمه كورونا وغيرها الكثير كل
هذا سينقلب في الاول من يناير لانه في هذا
التاريخ سيكون دا سيلفا هو الرئيس
وسييفقد بونسونر وحصنته الرئاسيه وحينها
لن سيكون صيدا سهلا للمحكمه العليا فقط
وانما حتى للمحاكم الادنى ولا تتوقف متاعب
سونار وعند هذا الحد حيث تلاحق الاتهامات
افرادا من عائلته وفي مقدمته نجله فلافيو
عضو مجلس الشيوخ المتهم بالاختلاس وتبييض
الاموال كما ان هناك تحقيقات اخرى تتهم
افرادا من عائلته بالاستحواذ على 51 عقارا
تم دفعه ثمنها بالكامل او جزء منها نقدا
بمبلغ اجمالي يصل الى نحو
4.8.€
حاول تامين نفسه بفرد السريه لمده 100 نعم
على عدد من الوثائق الرسميه او الشخصيه
التي يمكن ان تؤدينه لكن وعد بالفعل برفع
السريه عن هذه الوثائق بمجرد استلامه
الرئاسه
يذكرنا وضع بونسنار الحالي بشخص ما ربما
ذلك اا اا اطلق على سونار او اطلق عليه
ترامب الاستوائي ربما ترامب الاصلي
اذا بالعوده لمتاعب السونار مع التغيير
الحادث البرازيل هناك شخص اخر سيعاني من
المتاعب والمقصود هنا الرئيس جو بايدن
الرئيس الامريكي ذكرنا من قبل ان عوده
لولاد سيلفا تعطي زخاما للمد الوردي او
المد اليسار في امريكا الجنوبيه لتكمله
سلسله ضمه مؤخرا كولومبيا وتشيلي ستعاني
مهمه بايدن في السيطره على فنزويلا لانه
سيفقد حليفا مهما في هذه المحاوله خاصه
وان الحليف هو كبير القاره البرازيل سنعود
بالتاريخ الى يناير من عام 2019 حينها قطع
ترامب العلاقات مع حكومه الرئيس ولي
الاشتراك
نيكولاسما دوروا بعد اعاده انتخابه التي
اعترض عليها زعيم المعارضه
اعترفت واشنطن
لفنزويلا لكن الرجل لم يستثمر هذا الامر
سياسيا عدا عن انه فق ثقله بعد ان انتهى
البرلمان المنتخب فتره ولايته في يناير من
العام الماضي لذا يصف في الجونسون كبير
المحللين في مشروع انديز التابع لمجموعه
الازمات الفكريه ان عزل مادور والاعتراف
بحكومه مؤقته خياليه كان فكره غير مستدامه
اين فنزويلا التي كانت ترامب ومن بعده
بايد يسعى يعني الى تحجيمها في عالم اليوم
روسيا عزيزه علاقاتها العسكريه مع مدوره
حتى خلال الحرب العسكريه المستمره في
اوكرانيا ايران تمكنت من ابرامي صفقات
نفسيه معركه تحدي عقوبات ترامب المفروض
على البلدين بالمناسبه وايضا بالنسبه
للصين كانت فنزويلا احدى اكثر البلدان
البلدان التي يتزايد فيها النفوذ الاقتصاد
والسياسي لبيكين سنعود في الجونسون لتحليل
الوضع في امريكا الجنوبيه وتاثيرها على
خطه
المزيد من الدول سحبت اعترافها بجوايد
والتغيرات في كولومبيا والبرازيل هي
تقريبا مسامير الاخيره في نعش سياستها
[موسيقى]
رحله الطيران خاصه نظمتها السلطات
الايرانيه من مطار بغداد لنقل عدد من قوات
الحشد الشعبي وكتائب حزب الله الى مدينه
مشهد شمال شرقي ايران لقمع الانتفاضه
الشعبيه للايرانيين ضمن النظام
الماضي
الداميه للتظاهرات التي تواصلت حتى شهرها
الرابع في البلاد
تقارير تلقاها موقع ايران انترناشونال
تفيد بتنظيم رحله طيران خاصه من مطار
بغداد نقل فيها عدد من قوات الحشد الشعبي
وعناصر حزب الله الى مدينه مشهد شمال شرقي
ايران
في خطوه من طهران لتعزيز قواتها في
المنطقه بها في قمع الانتفاضه الشعبيه ضد
النظام
وبحسب المعلومات التي تلقتها ايران
انترناشونال فان الرحله الخاصه من مطار
بغداد نقلت 150 شخصا تقريبا تتراوحوا
اعمارهم بين 25 عاما يرتدون زيا واحدا
وحقائب سوداء سافروا الى مشهد من القسم
الخاص بالمطار لقمع الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
هناك وكانت لطيران تحركات مماثله خلال
السنوات الماضيه بخصوص ارسال قوات قمعيه
الى ايران من احزاب المواليه اوضاع ايران
حقوقيا من سيئا الى اسوء كما يرى مراقبون
منذ بدء الاحتجاجات واعداد الضحايا
انتقلين بازدياد
كما عبرت منظمه حقوق الانسان في ايران عن
قلقها من اوضاع المحتجين المعتقلين بسبب
الاحكام القاسيه التي اصدرها القضاء
الايراني والتي تشمل الحكم بالاعدام
سلطان العربيه
في جوف الحوت الازرق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
قبل اقل من اسبوع على الانتخابات النصفيه
حيث امرت المحكمه العليا في الولايه
المتارجحه بمنع احتساب اصوات الاقتراع
القادمه عبر البريد اذا كانت لا تحتوي على
التاريخ او تم تاريخها بشكل غير صحيح من
قبل ان خبير وكان الحزب الجمهوري في
الولايات رفع دعوى تطالب بعدم احتساب هذه
الاصوات حيث سيؤدي القرار الى استبعاد
اصوات ناخبين يميلون الى الحزب الديمقراطي
ويفضلون التصويت بالبريد بدلا من الذهاب
الى الاقتراح
[موسيقى]
ثلث مقاعد مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي مطروحه في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي الا انا عدد قليل
من هذه المقاعد هي الحاسمه للاغلبيه الوضع
الحالي يتساوى الحزبان في مجلس الشيوخ وكل
حزب يسعى لاغلبيه يحسمها مقعد واحد فقط
المزيد في العرض التالي مع زميل حمزه
احتزام المعارك لدخول الغرفه العليا في
الكونجرس امتد الى الصحراء الامريكيه اي
اريزونا ففي اريزونا يتقدم السيناتور
الديمقراطيه ماركلي على الجمهوريه بلاك
ماسترز الذي يعد رمزا لسياسه ترامب ولكن
يبقى التنافس شديدا اما في ولايه نيفادا
المجاوره فهناك فرصه كبيره للجمهور ادم
لاكسسلط امام كاثرين كورتيز ماستو علما
بان الاخيره اول ولا لاتينيه تحصل على
مقعد في مجلس الشيوخ عام 2017 الى ولاياتي
حزام الصدا اي الولايات الامريكيه المحيطه
بمنطقه البحيرات العظمى في الشمال الغربي
هذه الولايات تعد ارض المصانع الديمقراطيه
تاريخيه
وسقطت بعيد ترامب على خلفيه ساره رجع
التصنيع بينها وانديانا ومشيجن واوهيا
في ولايتي اوهايو المنافسه تدور بين تمرين
والوافد الجديد الى سياسه الامريكيه جي
ديفانس الذي يدعمه ترامب فيما يسعى
الجمهوريه في ولايه ويسكانسن رون جونسون
للاحتفاظ بمقعده في مجلس الشيوخ في مواجهه
الديمقراطيه مندل
فاز في ولايه ويسكانسن عام 2016
لكنها اكسبت بيدن السباق عام 2020
[موسيقى]
نتحول الان الى الموجز الرياضي مع الزميل
محمد القناص
[موسيقى]
شكرا جزيلا راويه اخبار رياضه حياكم الله
اعلن حارس مرمى بايرن ميونخ والمنتخب
الالماني مانويل نوير عن اصابته بمرض
السرطان الجلد ما يتطلب الخضوع ل 3 عمليات
جراحيه 10 نوير الى ان المرض اصاب وجهه
ولذا فقد اتخذ قرارا بالتخلي عن استعمال
بعض المواد لمقاومه حراره الشمس ويستعد
انهيار لتسجيل عودته الى تشكيله بايرن
ميونخ الاساسيه نهايه الاسبوع حتى يكون
قادر على دعم المنتخب
كشف مدير الشؤون الطبيه في الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم اندروماسي عن معايير المختلفه
التي سيتم تطبيقها في المونديال المقبله
من ضمنها بروتوكول الحمايه من الارتجاج
الدماغي ماسي قال ان بروتوكولا للحمايه
سيكون دليلا ليشرحوا للطواقم الطبيه
للمنتخبات خطوه بخطوه لتنبيهم في حال وجود
صدمه دماغيه او كيفيه معالجتها والوقايه
منها خلال ممارسه كره القدم مع ستتابع
بالقول انه في حال حدوث ارتجاج دماغي
للاعب خلال مباراه فسيتم السماح للفريق
باجراء تغيير حتى لو كان قد استنفذ
التغيرات الخمسه المسموحين بها
نظمت وزاره الخارجيه الكوستريه حفله
لتكريم اعضاء المنتخب قبل رحلته من مرتقبه
للمشاركه في نهائيات كاس العالم ويشارك
منتخب كوستاريكا للمره السادسه في تاريخه
في نهائيات كاس العالم بعد ان تم وصف
اللاعبين بانهم سفراء
لم ينجح فقد البصر في الوقوف بين حب الطفل
البرازيلي بيدرو لكره القدم ورغبته في
الاستمرار بالاستمتاع بمباريات المونديال
الطفل البرازيلي قام بتصميم الملصقات
لمونديال قطر
الخاص
بدول اعاقه البصريه وبعد الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم بالتواصل مع عائلته ومع مدير
مكتب صناعه الالبومات في ايطاليا
والبرازيل لصناعه نسخه المعدله من البوم
بيدروا تصميم نسخ من الملصقات عليها
كتابات بنظام الرايل تضم ثلاثه
يتطلعوا ارسنال الانجليزي الى حسم صداره
مجموعتي في ختام المنافسات الدوري
الاوروبي لكره القدم من اجل عبور المباشر
الى ثمن النهائي ويتاهل متصدر كل متصدر كل
مجموعه الى الدور ال16 فيما يواجه صاحب
المركز الثاني احد اصحاب المراكز الثلاثه
او عفوا صاحب المركز الثالث من القادمين
من دوري الابطال في ملحقين مؤهل الى دور
السته عشر ويتصدر المجموعه الاولى بفارق
نقطه التين يعني عنده هولندي
الاردني
صاحب المركز الاخير فيما يلعب
وكده مايكل ارتيتا مدرب وارسنال ان الاعبه
بكاء ساكو سيكون جاهزا لمواجهه زيورخ في
الدوري الاوروبي غدا الخميس بعد ان ثارت
مخاوف بشان غيابه بسبب خروجه من مباراه
وهو يعاني من كدمه في الكحل
المقابل تبدو مهنته مانشستر يونايتد اذا
يحتل المركز الثاني في المجموعه الخامسه
بفريق 30 نقاط على الريال السداد وهو
مطالب بالفوز بفارق هدفين او اكثر ضد
مضيفه في اسبانيا لتصدر المجموعه بعد ان
سقط على ارضه امام الفريق الباسكي في اوضه
سافرت بهدف دونا رد وتغلب مانشستر على
مانشستر يونايتد في الجوله الماضيه في
الدوري الانجليزي بيننا خسر سيسيداد امام
الريال في مباراه الدوري الاسباني
ولا خياره امام فريق المدرب جوزيه مورينيو
وروما سوي الفوز على الضيف بلغاري في
العاصمه الايطاليه من اجل خطف المركز
الثاني عن المجموعه الثالثه اذا يتساوى
الفريقان بسبع نقاط لكل منهما خلف بيتيس
صاحب المركز الاول بثلاثه عشر نقطه
تالق كريم فؤاد وسجل هدفين وسهم في هدفين
اضافيين ليقود الاهلي للفوز باربعه اهداف
بهدف على الداخليه ويحقق انتصاره الثالث
على التوالي ضمن المنافسات الجوله الثالثه
من الدوري المصري الاهلي رصيده الى تسع
دقائق في الصداره فريق الاهداف عن الاتحاد
السكندري بينما رصيد الداخليه عندك
في المقابل نجح ام بي في ادراك التعادل
امام الزمالك
يتعدى الفريقان بهدف لمثلك كان الزمالك
انها الشوط الاول بتقدمه بهدف سجله احمد
سيد زيزو من ركله الجزاء قبل ان اختفاء
بهدف التعادل عبر احمد كلوشه قبيلا نهايه
اللقاء بثماني دقائق الزمالك اصبح رصيده
سبع نقاط ثالثا بينما
يبرز اخبار الرياضه
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك محمد الى صوره اليوم ما يطلع
الشيخ الفلسطيني في الخليل الصحف ويبدو
عليها الامتعاض من شيء قراه يبدو انه
يتذكر تاريخا حديثا واخر بعيد الطبع
بالطبع فعليا المشاهدين الصحيفه تقول ان
نتنياهو عائد بحكم اسرائيل بشكل اكثر
شراسه وبحكومه ستكون عصاها الغليظه
اليمنيه المتطرف بن غفير يعلم الشيخ ويعلم
منهم في عمره ان تجاربهم معنى ثانيهاه
اطول من حكم اسرائيل كان فيها الكثير
ليتذكروه الكثير من الابداعات
تصريح اليوم
مشاهدينا الحيتان الزرقاء تبتلع يوميا نحو
عشره ملايين قطعه من البلاستيك الدقيق
بحسب دراسه نشرتها مجله نيتشر كوميكيشن
لكن المشكله الاخطر ان الدراسه توضح ان
الحيتان لم تبتلع هذه الكميات مباشره
وانما وصلت اليها من الفرائس التي تغذت
عليها الاسماك اذا الاسماك التي ناكلها
نحن ايضا
اما فيديو اليوم فهمنا الكونغو
الديمقراطيه المدنيون هناك هاشم وقافله
لقوات حفظ السلام الامميه شرق البلاد
قذفوا القافله بالحجاره واشعل النار في
شاحنه واحده على الاقل كانت تنقل معدات في
الكونغو الديمقراطيه طبعا هناك يتنام
الغضب من فشل هذه القوات في حمايه
المدنيين من عنف الميليشيات لم يستطع
المدنيون الرد على المليشيات فافرغ غضبهم
في من يفترض ان يحميهم وهذا جرس وانذار
للمهمات الامميه في القناه السمراء فنطاق
الفشل يتسع ومعه ستمتد مزيد من الايادي
للحجاره هذا انت وقفت عند الحجاره